did you have like a  a creative approach to making a music  video where  you'd like to send in the footage from  different parts of the world  uh no no so i with music all the music  videos like  we'd meet up oh great for the music yeah  for the music videos we meet up  and uh i remember um when i met  offset he was just off his face man he  was just  [ __ ] just gone by he was just like yo  like i was like why  yeah i was like he wasn't even speaking  english to me  but uh as soon as we played the track he  was like oh  yeah he's just jamming out  and as soon as the music stopped he just  just sat down and just  went back into his shell yeah what power  to it man  that's where that yeah  dude